if you think that that the idea of
hustle culture is becoming is becoming
like please shed
like the thing about your Hustle is its
hustle with tons of substance right and
I feel like there's a lot of kids we're
just hustling docile and like they just
they're like well I think a lot of kids
are saying they're hustling hustle you
know what I mean
that's what you know that's what I'm
getting yeah I mean and by the way by
the way I'm just doing it to help the
people that are actually trying to do it
realize how much work it is I actually
hope somebody else comes out with daily
Z and shows unbelievable work-life
balance right it just shows her or his
seven hour days but just enormous
amounts of happiness with family and
bowling and learning new I'm gonna learn
how MIT this week like there I don't I
don't want to convince anybody to do
what I do I just want to clarify to
everybody that it like you say so this
is what you mean
I'm just look look it takes a lot of
work and you know the other thing that's
really helped a lot of people is people
like whoa you're already way more
successful than I am and I'm working
like half as much as you and I thought I
was working more than you because I
thought you were kind of saying it but
then reaping the benefits of the riches
if you're still doing that so it's a
context point so it's come up because of
my last 24 hours on snap I think um not
really you know
you know like once like four times a
year like I'll like collapse and go to
sleep at like 7:00 p.m. and I'll need
like a hardcore like 15 hour sleep but
and I started taking care of my health
about two years ago 18 months ago and I
was not I mean I don't think I've picked
up any more energy when I was 25 pounds
heavier and eating like [ __ ] and not
exercising I just have so much a natural
adrenaline I showed up to somebody's
podcast yesterday and he was Facebook
liveing and I went back and read all the
comments last night at midnight because
I don't get tired and literally
everybody's like this guy's on [ __ ]
drugs which is really interesting for LA
and they meant it cuz they know what was
like they're like like why do all these
guys have to take drugs till like and I
was like [ __ ] I've never even tried a
cigarette I've never done anything in my
life I'm like I've been left out from
all that good [ __ ] and people still
think it because I just had it's just
natural DNA I truly think it's the same
way as being pretty or six-foot-five
it's just something you were given and
like I like it I'm glad I like that I
can I truly truly I really believe what
I'm about to say and this is
hyperbolized to the moon I truly think
I'm the hardest-working person on earth
I truly believe that I just work 18
hours a day every day like I still
cool awesome thanks guys
you